ce que nous avons annoncé aujourd'hui est la
découverte d'un crâne d'enfant, une espèce homo naledia de quatre à
six ans éteinte
d'hominidé primitif à petit cerveau
et non seulement les crânes d'enfants sont rares
de toutes les espèces, peut-être les choses les plus rares que
vous puissiez trouver chez l'hominidé  record et
c'est spécial à propos de ce petit crâne
que nous avons nommé laissez ici le perdu
je détermine l'âge géologique qui est
la période pendant laquelle l'espèce
vivait et que si je peux vous donner un
âge central je dirais 250 000 ans
ms
nous pensions
l'idée de comportements ritualisés
dirigés vers les morts
mais son petit crâne a été retrouvé seul
juste le crâne sans corps sans mandibule et
donc la question doit être posée était-il
placé là parce qu'il n'a pas été traîné
par des charognards ni des prédateurs ni n'a été  il s'est
lavé là-bas,
nous
essayons toujours de déterminer quelle est la place
du propriétaire, quelle est sa
position importante à l'intérieur, que ce soit
lié à nous ou si ce ne sont pas
les deux qui ont des implications puissantes,
en particulier si homoleti effectue
le type complexe de rituels liés  à
mort que nous pensons commencer à
voir à travers tous les endroits où nous les trouvons,
il se peut que quelque chose comme home and
letty ait inventé ce genre de comportements
des centaines de milliers d'années avant que
les humains ne vous le fassent